hey guys it's justine and today we're
going to be talking about my top
apps of 2021 so obviously there's the
usual suspects like the youtube the
twitter the instagram the tick tock but
there are a lot of very random apps that
i've been really enjoying that i've been
using a lot of this year
so first we're gonna get into it and one
of those apps is actually the sponsor
for this video
a huge thank you to lifear for
sponsoring this video
and i was so excited when they reached
out about this app because it's actually
really really cool so it's an app that
enables anyone to help others with
any problem at any time from anywhere
it's one of the first mobile ar apps
that pairs video conferencing with
real-time augmented reality capabilities
it's kind of like facetime with this
added element for ar that lets you
interact with the environment and not
only just interact with the environment
on your end whoever is on the other end
will actually be seeing
that augmented reality experience right
from their phone
so we're gonna call jenna hi hi
watch this okay so what's so cool about
this is like if
i was filming and i was trying to show
you something right here
ah a circle yeah that's my camera i
could do a heart
it's cool i know two screens right here
and like i can move it around it stays
there yeah because it's all ar
um camera is here because i see the
camera now it makes sense
you can show me like what if you want to
put like some art on the wall like how
are you saying you don't like my art i'm
like wait are you writing draw
what is that personally i okay go back
to the wall okay
jenna i don't know if i want your name
on my wall though this is so
awesome like i feel like this would be
so cool like for our parents like doing
tech
support or something i'm very excited
about this well
i'll see you later yeah bye all right so
some other apps that i've been using
this one is very interesting this one i
actually do plan on making a full video
about but
it's called helium some of you who are
in the cryptocurrency world may
be very familiar with helium but what it
is there's these devices that are helium
miners and it's basically a little
device that connects to your internet
connection
at home your router so that's providing
internet connection
to your helium router which then is
connected to other helium routers
all around the world so this is
basically creating an open
wi-fi network for internet of things to
connect to these devices
so it's interesting because it's giving
internet access to devices that may
never have been able to have internet
before like dog collars
scooters they even have like these rat
traps that need
internet connection and by using these
miners you get rewarded in helium tokens
and those tokens can then be cashed out
for cash and it's very hard to explain
in under two minutes another app that
i've been using
quite a lot is called my leo and miley
was really amazing because it is a
really cool photo organizing feature and
what's great about it is it doesn't
store your photos on the cloud you're
able to sync all of your photos across
multiple devices
android mac pc ipads whatever it is that
this app will run on you're able to sync
all of those photos and it's really
great because i've been using it a lot
for
keeping all of my thumbnails and my
social photos organized so no matter
where i am or what device i'm on i have
everything here
it has photo tagging you can do
various albums so like here i have a
bunch of thumbnails that are all stored
in here
you can sort things by folders so i have
a lot of my android photos from
various android phones that just auto
connect to here it's super cool
another app that i've been using a lot
of is the dji virtual
flight i had made a video previously
talking about
the fpv drone that dji came out with so
what's cool about this app is it allows
you to
virtually simulate what it's like doing
an fpv flight and why this is cool is
flying fpv is very challenging but
you're able to connect this
to the dji headset and then you're able
to use the controller so it will
actually feel like you're out flying
when i was flying a lot a few months ago
i would do this every night before bed
just to practice and try to get better
another app that i've been using a lot
of is telegram
and what i've been using telegram a lot
for is i was doing a
video where i spent a week with my
oneplus 9 phone
it was so fun because i had set a limit
for myself that that was the only device
that i was going to use for a week and
it actually turned into two weeks
because i got so
comfortable using it that i just was
kind of going about my way so i was able
to send
high quality photos and videos right
from my computer
to telegram that then were sent to my
oneplus phone because i was connected on
telegram and it was so cool because it
was so
seamless and i did not feel hindered at
all and like i said all of the usual
suspects
instagram i also use the threads app
instead of popping
into instagram just to you know send
people a message
this is just basically your instagram
dms it's
kind of like a little inbox you've got
youtube we got the youtube studio of
course tick tock spotify and then
twitter this is something that's also
kind of interesting this is called a
cube station
and i don't have it hooked up right now
but
this is the cube station i
got into um cubing over the pandemic
and it was strange because this all came
about because i
hit myself in the head with my phone and
i thought that i gave myself a
concussion
and when i was reading like how do you
tell if you have a concussion my results
determined by not going to a doctor but
by googling that i had a mild concussion
the one thing that it suggested that if
you have a concussion that you should do
brain games and i was like well what am
i gonna do
i've always wanted to learn to solve a
rubik's cube so then i made that like my
pandemic challenge to be able to solve
one
and then i thought okay i'm getting
pretty decent
at this algorithm that i have managed to
learn so i am able to solve the cube
almost under two minutes now which i
think is like pretty good i was getting
concerned that i wasn't
actually scrambling the cube good enough
so i was looking up for cube scramblers
and then i found this
thing it's so cool because once you have
it linked up to bluetooth on your phone
you're able to not only scramble the
cube but it connects to it so every move
that you do
is tracked on the phone and if you end
up stuck and you can't solve it this
will solve it for you
i know did anybody just say that i
spilled coffee on myself
did you see that yeah
so anyway my new pandemic hobby it's
been so much fun
and honestly i want to get better at it
and this has kind of helped me because
it's given me more challenging solves
because i'm not the one that is
physically
scrambling the cube so it's pretty cool
another app that i've
actually been using quite a lot during
the whole gamestop and amc trading
fiasco i downloaded public which is a
social trading app
now i'm not giving you any investment
advice with helium
or with public but it's really cool to
kind of jump into
investing but have like this social kind
of conversation around it to make it a
little bit more easy to understand so
i've really been enjoying kind of
getting into stock investing now i do
have someone that does manage actual
investments
but this is really fun because it's
something that i can do right in my
phone
doing small trades and being able to get
feedback on the things that i'm doing
and sometimes i don't really want the
feedback but you get it regardless so
it's like you have this whole social
feed
of people talking about various stocks
what they've
sold and it's really fun if you guys
want to be my friend on there i'll put a
link in the description
another app that has just really
kind of took over a lot of my time
recently since i was back visiting my
family
the flight that i took didn't have wi-fi
and one of the things that's cool about
apple arcade is a lot of their apps you
don't have to have an internet
connection to play
so i had downloaded this game called
story time
i was testing it out whenever they
launched a bunch of new games so it's
called simon's cat
story time i played this game it was
just kind of passing the time on this
overnight flight
not having very much fun at all and then
i played this game and
now i have played it i think over 30
hours over the last month
which is um you know i mean i guess it
averages you know like an hour a day
which is
fine but i'm on level 258
i have been building out my little
garden area here it's cool because it's
like a little
like comic book story that's kind of
going through and
super interactive and the type of game
that it is
that is sort of tying it all together
are like these little
matching games and like these types of
games to me
are so addictive
so fun another random app that i've been
using is um
it's for my grill i just got a traeger
grill
and this app will connect to your grill
it'll send recipes to it so that you'll
be able to monitor the time that you
need to cook and it'll also give you the
recipes on here so you can kind of prep
everything and then
toss it in the grill i know crazy it's
so funny to think of
how different my app usage is kind of
from year to year like a lot of these
things
i have never grilled in my life and now
this is a very common app that i've been
using
and a lot of these recipes like you can
actually you can make them
even if you don't have the grill but
obviously it is set to connect to the
grill to be able to give you the precise
times to cook
the right temperatures and whatever but
there's like cookie recipes on here
like it's pretty freaking awesome
another app that i use a lot
is called lumafusion it's a mobile
editing platform
that is available on ipad and on your
iphone and it makes editing
like high quality videos very very easy
it also supports hdr you can do 4k
content and they are coming out with a
multi-cam editor
in i'm not sure exactly when the release
date is but very excited about that
i have a demo that i did in my ipad
review video
so i got a chance to check that out and
i'm so so excited for it so yeah if
you're looking for
mobile editing solutions definitely
check out lumafusion i'd love to hear
from you guys if there's any unique apps
that you've been using that you think
that i might enjoy
feel free to leave them in the comments
below or send me a tweet i do spend a
lot of time on twitter so
that's probably a good way to reach me
thank you guys for watching i will see
you in my next video